Puerto Rico is in the middle of a
humanitarian disaster millions of
Hurricane Maria victims are struggling
for basic needs many have no food no
water
no fuel and no electricity the power
alone could take months to restore in a
series of tweets last night President
Trump said the u.s. commonwealth's old
electrical grid was devastated but he
also mentioned the Puerto Rican
government's long-standing financial
troubles mr. Trump said it owed billions
of dollars to Wall Street and banks
which sadly must be dealt with
David beg no has been in Puerto Rico
throughout this crisis he's in San Juan
right now David good morning good
morning it's been six days since this
hurricane made landfall and people in
some of the hardest hit areas are still
waiting on food water that they can
drink the power's out the communication
grid is severely disabled across the
island rescues are ongoing this morning
people in some of the hardest hit areas
have not been able to communicate with
anyone since Maria made landfall
emergency supplies are arriving slowly
from the US mainland to help millions of
people still struggling across this
island FEMA administrator Brock long
we've got a lot of work to do it's the
worst hurricane that Puerto Rico has
seen Puerto Rico's governor Ricardo
rosio traveled with the National Guard
to deliver a satellite phone to the
mayor of San Sebastian satellite phones
are critical in allowing senior
government officials to communicate with
local leaders in some of the hardest hit
areas to category 5 hurricanes passing
through an island is unprecedented and
therefore the response needs to be on
President only a handful of flights are
trickling out of Puerto Rico's main
airport in San Juan we've been here 26
hours within the last 24 hours desperate
travelers crowded the ticket counters
hoping to get on one of the few flights
to the US mainland
we told the governor about the dire
conditions we witnessed why can't
you sent there right now I mean there
are babies who are naked in strollers
their parents are fanning them because
of your reporting that I saw last night
I ordered food and snacks to be
delivered to the airport today
I hear you but it's not getting to them
I understand and that's why immediately
I'm thinking action and I will as soon
as we finish the interview make sure
that waters it's on its way and food is
on he kept his word food and snacks
arrived within an hour the governor now
worries about the lasting effects if
Washington doesn't pass a financial aid
package soon humanitarian crisis will
come to the United States in the form of
the 3.5 million u.s. citizens that live
here and what you're about to see is a
massive exodus of Puerto Ricans in to
the mainland that's going to be a
problem for us that's gonna be a problem
for mainland as well
Puerto Rico's governor has complimented
the work that FEMA is doing and FEMA's
complimented the governor they both
complimented President Trump but we've
asked where is it happening allow us to
get video of it let us show the American
people that their loved ones are
receiving the aid that has been promised
we asked the governor will you take us
there and let us get video he guaranteed
us that he would we'll hold him to it
Gail yes we all want to see that thank
you very much David beg no reporting
from Puerto Rico